as the gruesome fighting in ukraine gets
worse by the day the entire world is
seeing the graphic footage women
children students innocent civilians are
being brutalized lacerated by shrapnel
gutted by russian machine gun fire and
reportedly vaporized by vacuum bombs the
carnage unleashed by russia's war
machine is sparing no one as they've
brought large-scale conventional combat
back to europe for the first time since
the blitz creek
back then in the late 1930s and early
40s the world was facing a different
kind of evil
hitler had taken control of germany and
was pushing his tanks across the
continent but in the face of real
villainy true leaders emerged and
perhaps there was no greater european
leader than winston churchill
after poland and france fell to germany
all that stood in the way of hitler's
european dominance was england and their
fearless prime minister
and with an unwavering belief in his
people churchill rallied britain and
they never gave in
we shall go on to the end
we can fight in france
which will fight on the seas and oceans
we shall fight with growing confidence
and growing strength in the air
we shall defend our island whatever
their cuts may be
we shall fight on the beaches
we shall fight on the landing grounds
we shall fight in the fields
and in the streets we shall fight in the
hills
we shall never surrender
hard times create strong leaders and
churchill was among the strongest
but as our eyes turned back to ukraine
another fearless leader has emerged to
give his people the faith they need to
fight back in hard times
vladimir zielinski the comedian who
became a president has become the face
of ukraine's resistance
and he is having his churchillian moment
when the fighting began and the bombs
started to fall
he could have fled to safety in the west
but he refused to abandon his people
we are all here
our soldiers are here the citizens are
here and we are here we defend our
independence that's how it'll go
the importance of zelensky to his people
cannot be understated the more intense
the fighting gets the more powerful his
message of defiance becomes
every day the people are rallying around
his words
think of this number almost 6 000
russians died
to get what get ukraine it is impossible
this is not to be changed by missiles
bombs tanks any blows today you
ukrainians are symbol of invincibility
and the whole world is picking up what
zylenski's putting down the united
nations gave him a standing ovation this
week a place that doesn't normally know
what it's doing
now it does
for the ukraine zielinski is the white
knight of kiev but to putin he's public
enemy number one and zielinski knows
what's at risk
according to our information the enemy
marked me as the number one target my
family is the number two target they
want to destroy ukraine politically by
destroying the head of state
the longer zelinski is alive the worse
it is for putin and the better it is for
ukraine
putin knows this too which is why putin
slipped the chechen hit squad in dekeiv
but the assassination attempt failed as
the chechens were caught and eliminated
according to ukrainian officials
and now putin's become more ruthless
he's been committing war crimes using
weapons banned by the geneva convention
and directly targeting civilians
these are the actions of a terrorist
not the leader of a civilized nation
and earlier this week putin put russia's
nuclear forces into a heightened alert
status trying to strike fear into the
heart of nato countries and keep them
out of the fight
while raising concerns across the globe
that putin was preparing for world war
iii
russia's foreign minister mr lavrov even
went as far as to issue a warning that
such a war will be quote
a nuclear and destructive one
the united states has decided to lower
the temperature
in an effort to demonstrate
that we have no intention
in engaging in any actions that could be
misunderstood
or misconstrued
the secretary of defense has directed
that our minuteman 3 intercontinental
ballistic missile test launch
scheduled for this week
to be postponed
and we did not take this decision
lightly but instead to demonstrate that
we are a responsible
nuclear power general david petraeus is
going to join me soon to discuss whether
that was the right call
america cannot be caught flat-footed
here which is why i was encouraged to
see our fighter jets in japan
showcased in an elephant walk formation
reminding the world that we're prepared
for anything
while our country's doomsday plane
designed to protect high-ranking
government officials from a nuclear
attack was sent on a four-hour training
flight
we are ready if putin decides to make
this a worldwide fight but until then
we're still standing with president
zielinski and the ukrainian people
we need to help him
and do whatever we can to keep zielinski
safe
how worried are you about president
in your valencia or do you think you can
try to lead i think it's his judgment to
make and we're doing everything we can
to help him
we need to help zielinski as much as we
can but him leaving the country would be
a severe blow to the ukrainian army
and the civilian resistance we need to
continue to send anti-tank weapons and
missile defense tools to the ukrainian
people as long as zelinski remains
inside the ukraine there is hope for his
people
even if he has to go underground
the protection of zielinski is priority
number one for the entire western world
he's become a symbol larger than life
he recognizes this and appears to know
he may have to die in the capital to
save his country
despite their overwhelming military
resources russia is losing the battle of
morale
there are now reports of russian troops
abandoning their convoys emptying their
own gas tanks and calling it quits
rather than fight their neighbors
there is a propaganda war going on with
ukraine it's being fought on all sides
and zielinski is the key character
the west cannot lose him the ukrainians
cannot lose him and so the united states
must help execute a survival strategy to
keep zielinski and hope
alive
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else